is yeah women love bad boys no no I
don't I don't think I don't know I don't
think you don't think that's true no no
if we misrepresentation
misrepresentation or something it's not
that women like bad boys in itself yeah
it's that bad boys a lot of the time are
more connected to their masculinity
what do you mean by yeah
okay women are attracted to a man who
can lead right and a man's confidence
has confidence bad boys have those
traits so when a woman is attracted to a
bad boy it's not that she's attracted to
someone treating her so all bad boys
have leadership qualities and all nice
guys don't have leadership qualities
well let's look at it the the reverse
most nice guys end up being Sims because
they're missing them
I think it's Paul I think that for me I
think it's poor understanding okay so
when so when you say women like Bad Boys
the women that like bad boys look at the
type of women we're talking about it's a
quality control issue like me no offense
to you but if I see a man covered in
touch with like covered I'm just like yo
right
okay
[Applause]
do you know what it is yeah you gotta
know yourself and know your Market yeah
all right you gotta know your Market bro
no no no it's your entitled to what you
like no no no but what I'm saying is
there's certain there's certain
stereotypes that are classified with bad
boys and a certain reputation right I
grew up in Edmonton as I said there's
certain man that I grew up with I will
never date them because I know their
mentality and I know how they operate
and I know you know them personally
no no no no no I know them personally
and I know the image they're trying to
portray but that's different if you know
them personally if you don't know it in
person so if I don't know them
personally the way you speak to me the
way you operate when you're dealing with
me I'm a stranger you know there's bad
boys that wear suits
English they're all the king's English
how do you define a bad boy no no no
it's let's start that what how do you
add the film
obviously it goes back to you know the
parameters of when you're making that
decision on the guy as I said is he
family orientated like what kind of
person is it what kind of background
does he come from it's all of those kind
of elements if it's just a guy you've
met and you know I don't know you just
talk sexual from the jump right or he's
trying to impressive material things or
his status more than likely he just
wants to use you can I just say
something right we're talking about
single parents and we're talking about
these top whatever percentage of men
who's having these children with the
single pyramids
it's not the time yeah it's the regular
the same God no it's most of the time
most of the women are sleeping with the
same men no I'm not talking about
sleeping with because I'm having kids no
because all those were out there that uh
like you said you're going for the the
top class man yeah those are not the
ones that are breeding those are not the
ones that how many single pyramids do
you see that got the men from that
whatever percentage Yeah they didn't but
what consists of that top percent that
could be looks that could be clout that
could be a lot of things
no but what I'm trying to say is that
it's a lot but it's a lot of things it
depends on the woman as well because
some women value certain things
differently you get what I'm saying some
women just care about clout some women
they just care about affluence no I'm
not disagree with you I'm talking about
single parents because we're talking
about single parents yeah what I'm
trying to say is that the single parents
out there the women that have got lots
of children what type of men have they
got their children for because it ain't
those top percent yeah okay
so I'm asking hold on hold on so let me
call everyone you're just talking about
the baby mamas that have a gang of kids
who are they having kids with that's
what you're asking okay yes because
right now we're talking about single
parents how many people because you
might find that a woman that's got like
those top whatever percent if they catch
you man they're gonna have one yeah yeah
you know what I mean because they know
that they can believe that man driver
just that one child but the ones that
have been three four five six seven days
I've done videos about that um what is
it she she had a kid with a basketball
player as soon as he got out of high
school or college yeah and had a kid
with him straight away she's not saying
and then and then and then what a month
or two later oh yeah let's break up
because she's a predator yeah that's
what I'm trying to say men need to watch
it but we're talking about debate you're
talking about like the baby mamas with
the five kids I'm just talking about
single parents in general if you get a
single parent for them top percent the
woman had an agenda from the start she
was preying on that man but the single
the ones that are out there that we're
talking about all the baby mothers what
is the incentive because ain't the money
because they're not going for that guy
they're just dumb yeah it's the game for
the other ones but you know why because
other men they can have one they can be
the first
because how many single parents are you
know out there that have more than or
they have on average five children and
they're all from the same dad yeah and
when you look and when you no I'm
serious and when you look at the
children you will see that's the first
for that man that's the first for that
man that's the first for that man that's
the first for that man and that's what
I'm trying to say is that they want
if I have you like you
if I was a woman then I was single I'm
praying on you you're the man I'm
targeting all the way you're the man
that I'm targeting because you got it
together now seriously you've got it
together and you had no child and you're
passionate about looking after a child
you understand what I'm saying so I
would go for you and if me and you
didn't work and I know he had no
children
and I can get close to him and he first
the same mentality as you I'm gonna go
for him you know what because I'm set
with you for the next 18 21 years I'm
all right because you're always going to
be involved all right so what kind of
person is so what kind of woman is that
in your opinion it's like but I'm trying
to say that there you go what I'm trying
to say is that how they become single
parents the mentality of it that's what
I'm trying to say selfish yeah I think I
think this is
sorting out their future and their
pension and I think it's different I
mean there's different levels for this I
think I think I don't think they're all
the same I think there's different types
of women that do it for different
they're all wrong but they do it for
different reasons they're the ones that
like you're describing absolutely and
then there's there's the ones that oh he
was just oh my God he's so good looking
I just want to trap him I wanted to keep
him but that baby cannot keep him he's
gone like the last time was that Man's
first child that they want to keep
that's what that's exactly what you said
is correct but it's always and when you
hear a woman say that because yeah got
no kids you will hardly hear a woman say
that for a man that's got loads of kids
well you know I mean it happens and I'm
not going to say it happens but most of
the time when you get these young girls
they're looking for a man that ain't got
none
they got it together women do not no but
women do not have as I said women do not
have children for men they do not like
regardless of money or not and and no no
no no no no no no
there's no Finance
there's no Financial incentive no no
what I'm saying is if
regardless there isn't like Auntie said
there always is because the government
is the financial institute but what I'm
saying is a woman will not have a child
I could be in ends and the guy is broke
he deals Rose whatever I don't know what
he does he's broke as hell he's at the
bottom of the barrel if I like him and
he gets me pregnant why would I bully I
like him regardless of regardless of if
he's a good dad or not if I don't have
the capacity and understanding that
should have been passed down to me from
my father or my family I'm gonna have a
child by this guy
yeah but if that if that were true then
people wouldn't be trying to steal
Drake's condoms
yeah but he has money yeah
no no but what I'm saying we're talking
about our level the single mothers on
our level is a lot it's not the Rich and
Famous they're the ones you hear about
because of who they are we're talking
about everyday Jody and Helen and Marsha
or whoever yeah every day Jamal can pick
up two boxes and he's the rich man in
the ends so that's the level yeah no no
but that's not right
but that's not wealth every day
go out bangs it on the night out and
she's saying yes safe I'm set for life
and she could be from the hood or
whatever yeah she pretty she managed to
sneak herself in the after party yeah
but it's not it's nice
you're missing no point you're missing
my point my point is women do not have
children from when they don't like so
foreign
think about this how many times you've
seen couples where the woman is she
she's decent nice looking the man yeah
this doesn't yeah it's just because he's
gone yeah but you're but you're looking
no but you're looking at the visual what
I'm saying is okay we can say there's
women that sleep with men because of
money blah blah blah like Drake or
whoever but on our level if I get
pregnant I'm not talking about
celebrities don't talk about normal
people yeah there's something in it for
them right but regardless of that we you
have to like the man in some capacity I
like that he's got money I like his look
I like the man they just like the money
yeah
hold on I know it hurts it doesn't it
doesn't burn it doesn't burn it does but
anyway listen yeah hold on yeah problem
is yeah you're seeing it from your eyes
yeah you're saying you need to open to a
different range like I'm saying there
are women out there there's a load of
women out there that don't mind as long
as the guy's got peas they don't mind
bro the guy don't even really have to
have Peas Just just come out 100 it
happens yeah but that's the reason that
she likes him though sometimes there's
something about it that's not really
liking somebody yeah that's like oh yeah
I'm just gonna have that kid for you
because you got peas or you're you're
known in it like boom like I'm connected
to you that don't mean she like him no
also like what what sort of woman are we
talking about though because there's a
certain caliber of women that I think
will do that for the wrong reasons well
I think there's uh women who want an
affluent lifestyle that could be seen as
high class that they will get with a man
just for money as well absolutely
they're not ratchets they're not running
around having five baby daddies but
their mindset is I'm going to go for a
man that is of a certain class level and
certain money it doesn't really matter
if he's if he's smart funny it doesn't
really matter boom I want to stay at
home I want to look after my kids I want
to be a lady of Life yeah
how can you look after your kid when
everything that you're doing relies on a
man you're not looking after your kid
you're relying on a man to provide for
you no this is the issue we live in a
generation of women that say that you
know we're competing with men in a lot
of ways which we shouldn't be really
um
and we're independent but we still
expect men to provide for us so which
part are we doing the independent part
of the provision part which part are we
doing the bit you're forgetting here as
a man yeah you're not doing nothing for
your child regardless of the situation
whether you told her you didn't want it
or it was a one night or whatever you're
getting slated yeah you're getting
rubbed out it's long so to just avoid
all of that unnecessary headache that
man's gonna do it do you understand the
man's just going to provide just stop
giving me a headache and she's looking
at that she some some women I'm not
saying all of them but some women
actually just fully say I just want a
child I don't care about a guy bro I
don't even I don't even want a
relationship I just want a child in it
yeah really especially when they start
getting older yeah
especially when you get to a certain age
they're like because obviously we know
as women you you get to a certain age it
starts to pick up the older you get the
harder it becomes in it men we can keep
going get me whatever but certainly and
then get to a point where they're like
[ __ ] it cool now if I'm at that level
man I'm saying right I just want a child
who am I gonna look at I'm gonna look at
is he up that's the first thing is he up
[ __ ] if I like him [ __ ] if he's cute
is he up yeah but because now at least
it's not even only I'm not um
they look at it as this what is the best
option I've got right now yeah that's
literally yeah but you may okay to to
add some Spanish to the works if that
woman came to you now it's in your power
to make the decision if you're going to
sleep with her or not and give her the
yeah so if the answer is yes then you're
setting yourself up no
um
you know what I mean no but I do get
that but we're we're having a discussion
here you explained the whole whole
process to me yeah so you're aware of it
now you guys have to take his
accountability yeah no one is saying
that oh yeah man you know we're just the
victims
I'm not like I think you're getting me
wrong yeah see how you say men like
women lie too you know she's
coming to me with that intention where
she's trying to get pregnant or whatever
she's got her agenda More Time When
people's got the agenda they don't tell
you yeah until you figure it out later
on when it goes to [ __ ] yeah that's
normally how it goes No One's Gonna Come
and tell you their Master evil plan at
the beginning and then you're gonna walk
into it like then you're just the idiot
in it you know what I'm trying to say so
she's got that agenda you're still going
in but you're saying brother I'm not
hitting this rule yeah Jimmy boss you're
done you get me you don't even know
nothing about it Jimmy boss you're done
or is she telling you on a pill if
you're taking that risk as a man to
still hit a raw while she's on the pill
obviously we know it's not 100 they'll
still get pregnant on the pill when it
is what it is as many of you know I was
just banned on Tic Tac and we are
demonetized on a daily basis on this
platform if you want to help please
consider sending a super thanks below
every donation helps and it helps make
what we do possible